all right hello everyone
good morning good afternoon and uh and
welcome
uh today we've got a pretty
action-packed uh calendar i think
uh ncbi has graciously agreed to
give us an overview of where they
currently sit with uh with stat
and some of their sra submission
processes
uh and uh some eagerly awaited updates
on
not only the hopefully the uh the sra
side but also potentially some of the
local
host removal tools that are available
and jeremy and emma and noah and others
have
agreed to give us a brief overview of
their recent paper on
677 variants so we might get into a
little bit of ornithology while we're
there
uh before we go on though uh i wanted to
um so there's the agenda for today uh
give a quick update on in terms of
numbers uh
u.s submissions right now are at 110 269
in uh in guess aid uh that is uh
an up increase in of about 10 000 over
the last week
uh we've had some some minor hiccups in
getting some of the uh the commercial
sequence data into
into kiss 8 and genbank but i think a
lot of that has been resolved over the
past
past couple days i would think through
diligent efforts on
on all fronts uh but i think that should
resolve itself fairly quickly and we
should see an uptick in both
uh pretty dramatically if some of these
large sequencing efforts start to come
online
uh in terms of genbank submissions that
translates to uh
just over forty one thousand forty one
thousand four hundred 1420
uh which is just i have 3 000 since that
since the last update last week
uh hopefully we will start tracking sra
submissions pretty soon
uh because i think that's going to be an
important addition as well
but you know obviously things are
starting to increase pretty
pretty dramatically and i would imagine
that things will continue to accelerate
as submissions
continue to increase just in the
interest of time i'm going to
kick it over to uh to chris o'sullivan
and yuri and whoever else from ncbi is
going to drive today
i'm really looking forward to this
update and can't wait to see what
they've got in store
chris over to you hi thanks
i'm broadcasting live from my fabulous
basement office
um so my lighting is terrible apologies
if i look like a psychopath
um anyway um i'm here um
i've got my um one of my uh
one of my developers who's going to do
the bulk of the
technical talk for us um i'm going to
introduce it by just
talking about why on earth ncbi decided
to develop their own
human reed scrubber which
was a well basically it it led to the
development of our
taxonomy analysis tool and we have just
submitted
a paper on that describing the full
technique
and methodology i believe there may be
a bioarchive link which will be
available in the talk
coming up shortly from uh
from the developer who i'll introduce
shortly
um i just wanted to give the background
that um
back in uh the beginning of the human
microbiome project
there was um some concern
uh that some of the uh microbiome data
would contain
some re some reads from the host
a lot of people thought oh well we're
just doing pcr amplicons
at the beginning of the project why
would there be any human reads in there
well there are there are a lot of them
so we had um you know in
at ncbi we've got a fantastic developer
her name is
risha agrawala and she had been working
on
building an alignment
an alignment tool and she quickly
adopted that
to create a uh you know a branch that
would
find human reads within an sra data set
flagged them and then sra would
blank them out and this worked
fantastically
uh for the human microbiome project but
that worked in the specific context of
hmp submissions
which uh because of um the nature of the
project
uh they came in uh as dbgap projects
meaning they came in with a lot of host
phenotype data
so they had to go through the dbgap
submission process
now when ncbi first stood up the dbgap
portion of sra we actually created a
physically isolated
file system just to make sure that we
would um
we're not leaking you know any
personally identifiable
sequence information and that it was
inaccessible to anybody who
should not have access to it and so
these hnp submissions would come in and
we would run
a humanoid you know an alignment against
the human reference genome
and then create the filtered copy of a
file
to copy into the public side of sra for
distribution of just microbiome data
a few years later we started working
with
the fda and cdc on
foodborne pathogen surveillance and
there were some requests from
some potential submitters about uh
possibly applying a you know human
filter to their submissions
now since these were not dbgap
submissions they would be coming
directly to public
and on the public side just the
technicalities of the way ncbi processes
data
we um sra is one client of very many
uh using a shared compute resource
so we realized that these um
jobs were not you know these human
scrubber jobs were not getting
queued efficiently or quickly
basically a human reference index is
a 15 to 20 gigabyte file
and when you're requesting resources on
a shared compute resource
you have to request memory and then you
have to wait for a host to be available
and then you have to move the file and
it's not very fast to move
a 20 gigabyte file so
right about that time serendipitously we
had a new developer join the team
he just left microsoft for reasons
that i'll leave alone he had no
background in bioinformatics
no background not really much background
in biology
and i thought well maybe this is perfect
we'll just take a completely fresh
approach
i'll just present him the issue
and we'll figure out a way to make a
smaller reference index that's my
big dumb biologist approach to things
like
well there's got to be a way to make a
smaller index like we don't actually
need
reference placements we don't need to
know where in the genome these things
align we just need to know whether or
not it was human
and so after a week or so of
of um discussing the issue and and
talking to
this new developer oleg i taught him a
lot about biology
a lot about microbiomes a lot about dna
structure and sequence analysis
i mean just the basics you know as much
as someone could learn in a week
and he said i think i can go figure
something out
my suggestion was well let's just start
de-duplicating the um
you know human reference let's uh let's
let's throw out the uh
low complexity sequence maybe we'll make
a smaller index that way
and well after a couple of weeks he came
back and he said to me
we can do this we can reduce the size of
the index
by 50 fold or maybe more
and then he said and i think you know
basically i said all we need to do is
find
reeds that are definitely human and
definitely not something else we just
want to eliminate the false negatives
and uh he said yeah we could probably do
this for all organisms
but anyway this was the uh this was the
start of what became our taxonomy
analysis
tool and um
i would like to turn it over to another
developer on our team
um because unfortunately oleg had to
leave ncbi
he took a job with spacex which is a
typical fate for
many ncbi developers um he's actually
rejoined us recently but um
i'd like to introduce you to ken katz
who
has dug into the tool uh sorted out the
code
and actually uh written it up as a
publication
and he's going to walk you through the
technical aspects of how this thing
actually works
thank you chris i really appreciate that
and
uh first let me apologize you notice i'm
not
sharing uh a video which was
my bad in terms of setting up my zoom
but
then i realized because many in this
audience are from the cdc
it's really bad uh many of you
may know a kenneth cats kenneth a katz
who i know but who i am not ken used to
work at cdc
uh he's a dermatologist and his father
steve katz his late father steve katz
was a colleague of mine
because i'm trained as an immunologist
and i didn't want anyone
out there thinking that ken had returned
yet again
to the dc area he's still out in
california
apology and i meant to introduce you as
my favorite type of developer the
biologist
who decided to take up programming
instead
thanks chris so what i'm going to do
first of all is just introduce you to
some of the key concepts
of our ncbi stat tool the sequence
taxonomy come on you can say it
analysis tool and the reason we call it
stat
is because i like to be able to breathe
when i'm talking about it and that's a
mouthful
now stat really refers to a collection
of tools and these collection of
tools are for building k-mer databases
for querying those databases for
reporting the results of those queries
and what they have in common what they
share in common
are two key concepts and these two
key concepts are what allow
both stat and the human scrubber which
is based on stat
to be accurate and fast
and scalable so the first key concept
is called minihesh minhash
was developed by andre broder
back in the early days of the web and
it's really a deceivingly simple concept
but it is the key concept that allows
that to be scalable and fast
and the minhash principle simply states
that a random selection of the lowest
valued constituent blocks in a pool
after hashing
represents a signature of the parent
object
don't worry about that big sentence
because i'll break it down
a bit what broder was concerned about
back in the early days of the web if you
can remember through those misty
misty vision in your eyes the um
web viewer browser alta vista
they were concerned about how do i tell
whether two
web pages are the same or are different
now i was not imaginative and in the 80s
when i was staring at my arpanet screen
if somebody had asked me that question i
would have said
oh look at the two pages and i'll tell
you if they're identical
and what people like broder realized
was that that's not really a scalable
method
and it's not going to work and they
presciently saw
that there was going to be an explosion
in web pages so
you really needed something better so
the idea here
again first we're going to take a random
selection of the lowest value
constituent blocks so if a web page is a
bunch of words say 10 000 words
what we might do is have a sliding
window of three or four words
and we're going to slide that window
through the document
and now we need to assign a value
to that window of words because we want
to find the lowest value
of those words and so maybe
you might assign the numerical value to
a letter
of its position in the alphabet a equals
one b
equals two that's about as ingenious as
i can get
um so you can imagine now
sliding that window generating values
for
each of the words and the letters that
make up those words in that window and
now you simply select the lowest valued
constituent blocks and because
this is a sampling method you may be
comparing two web pages that are a
hundred thousand words each
but in fact you could just grab a
handful of these
lowest valued constituent blocks maybe
ten each and by this principle
if those two handfuls were similar
it would tell you those two parent
objects are similar so now you can
immediately see
that this is scalable and where things
are scalable they become
very very fast one thing i should point
out is
minhash is widely accepted it's used in
not only in many areas of bioinformatics
but
more famously because it was based on
words it's used for furthing out
plagiarism
now in sra our parent object is of
course a nucleotide sequence
and so when we implement minhash what
we call the constituent blocks are
k-mers and a k-mer is just a polymer of
length k
and our blocks are nucleotide polymers
of length k
and what we're going to say is from a
set of sequences we're going to read a
window
our window is going to be 32 base pairs
so these are 32 base pair cameras those
are our
constituent blocks and we're going to
read them across a window
and then we're going to transform them
into a 64-bit hash
and just as i described for the original
minhash we're going to select
the minimum value k-mers and they are
going to be representative of that
parent
set of sequences and i would
point out uh crucially
that for every camera that we ultimately
select we store the tax id for the
sequence
it was derived from now let's
just focus a bit on how we really do a
k-mer
minhash selection in panel a
i just show a random sequence and above
that sequence
i've shown a bracket for a 64 base pair
segment below that sequence
are another series of brackets those
brackets represent
32 base pairs that's our sliding window
and what i'm showing below that sequence
is we are going to slide that 32
base pair window incrementing one base
at a time
across that 64 base pair segment
and so what we're going to do is
generate
64 32 base pair
sequence k-mers and then
from those 64 looking at both strands
we are going to apply our hash and then
select
the lowest valued tamer now in panel b
we can look at what we really mean by
creating a hash so first i've shown a 32
base pair sequence
just randomly from that original 64 base
pair segment
and the first step that we do is we
turn that 32 base pair sequence
by encoding each base in two bits
into a 64-bit binary array
this is a really simple code and it's
very standard in bioinformatics so
instead of each nucleotide taking up
eight bits or one byte
each nucleotide will now take up two
bits and that's a four to one
compression
and what i'm showing below that 32 base
pair sequence is literally
the 64-bit binary
uh array that represents
the sequence above it and now the real
trick that oleg
imparted to us was all you got to do
is read that 64-bit binary array
as a decimal so now if we do this very
operation for all
64 32 base pair
segments that we've generated in this
window
we simply read the decimal value of that
64-bit encoded sequence and choose
the single lowest value that's
our min hashed k-mer that's going to
represent
this 64-base pair segment
so that's how we implement
the minhash selection technique and
again that's really a key concept
because it obviously allows us to be
scalable
when we're selecting one out of every 64
possible k-mers
that means the size of our k-mer
database is much much smaller the amount
of memory
that you use much much smaller etc
however as i also said there were really
two key concepts to stat
and k-mer hashes by themselves do not
make a database
and the real key observation here
is that a result of evolution as we know
is that for any given
species most of the sequences in that
species
are not specific to the species but they
rather represent that lineage from which
that species arose
we all know that humans mostly have
primate and chimpanzees
even some gorillas certainly neanderthal
we now know
uh sequence and so
our task here the second key
in making an accurate database
is that for any given tax id we need to
identify
those k-mers that are diagnostic for
that tax id for that species
and in that process we can then move all
the
other k-mers up the lineage
to their lineage-specific appropriate
node
let me just give you a small uh
cartoon of how we do that in panel a
you can see depicted a genus in two
species
and what you can see in panel a is that
species and species b
have some k-mers unique to themselves
but they also
have two k-mers that they each contain
and those are indicated in bold
and the idea here is we move to panel b
where we have taken those k-mers that
are not
diagnostic for either species a
or species b we assume
they are diagnostic for some other node
on that lineage and we just
move them up to the genus and now we
have
only specific diagnostic k-mers for
species a
and species b and the key here
is we iterate this process starting at
the very leaves
of a taxonomic tree a bunch of species
out to your right or your left depending
on
whether you're left-handed or
right-handed and
we just started the species and do this
operation
up to the next level which might be a
genus or subgenus
and then iterate again and iterate again
and we do this
merging all the way up to the root of
the kingdoms
that's the step that makes us that
database
not just scalable and fast but accurate
now let's get to the human scrubber
and oleg as chris indicated
made a really special human scrubber
database for this purpose
what he started with was a green bucket
on the left
in which he generated representative
minhash
tamers from all human rust seek
sequences now what's key in that green
bucket
is no merging has happened so in that
bucket are all the human specific
diagnostic cameras as well as human
k-mers that represent
lineage what we're going to do
is subtract from that green bucket
the blue bucket which is all of
non-eukaryotic cameras and just to make
this
easy we we use the non-eukaryotic
uh k-mer merge tree that we generate
during
our normal normal stat building process
so if we subtract the blue bucket from
the green bucket
we're left with the yellow bucket that's
our very special human scrubber k-mer db
and this db has the following two
characteristics it is
very aggressive at identifying
a potential human read it's aggressive
because not only does it have those
diagnostic human k-mers in it
it also has k-mers that humans have
because they really represent primate
lineage or mammal lineage or
any other lineage up the eukaryotic tree
but the other key is
it is very conservative at maintaining
any potential viral or bacterial
clinical pathogen sequence so that's
what we want
aggressively remove a potential human
reed
do not touch the potential clinical
pathogen sample
this is the best slide and i really
appreciate all of oleg's work
because this is all you have to do
it's this simple to scrub you have an
input sequence which might be
input faster q that just means this is
the faster q
sequence the fastq i always say faster q
excuse me
the fastq sequence which was the output
of your sequencing run
and you hand it to the scrubber the
scrubber's just going to chop it into 32
base pair cameras
it's going to align it in some sense
with the k-mers
in this very special k-mer database and
what it
outputs is a new fastq
file and that is your original fastq
file minus any of the spots
or reads that had potential
human pii it's really
that simple
how good is the scrubber this is a very
key
observation by oleg
so using this example excuse me of
a run this record
is actually one of the first clinical
samples from
uh wuhan and it's bronco bronchoalveolar
lavage just just a little washing of
broncho
alveolar tissue and lavage expects to
find mostly lymphocytes in an infected
patient
with some unknown pathogen uh epithelial
cells and of course hopefully a viral
pathogen
so this this run had over 5 million
spots
and this 5 million paired reeds
essentially 1.5 gigabase pairs of
of sequence and we and the read length
is variable
as it typically is reads going from less
eight
less than 80 base pairs to about 150
basters actually in this case i think
even some
up to 170 or 80. and we knew
from the stat analysis that of those
greater than 5 million spots 91.54 per
of those spots were eukaryotic
so from the point of view of our human
scrubber
that means there should be four million
seven hundred ninety six thousand
four and 442 human spots
in that run set so when we ran the
scrubber
we removed 99.97
of those human spots and i and it's in
yellow on this slide because that is
really impressive
99.97 of human spots were removed
of the 0.03 percent
that remain they tended to be
in fact in the cases i looked at they
were always
short reads and typically of low
complexity
these are not reads that are going to
contain any pii
information so as you can see
the slide says a little demo and i
believe there's enough time for this
simple demo i'm just going to show you
that i'm starting with a local file
that's a fastq file and
i'm now going to execute this command
which is just running a docker file this
docker image
is public by the way it is sort of a
beta version because i have not had time
to put
a test in it but you can try it and
we do uh have on the slides we've
put its location and
there i am running running the docker
image i'll just point out that the first
part of that command
is really standard docker verbiage
you're just passing the docker image
your present working directory and
you're allowing the docker image to read
it local
locally and write and write to it
locally and the reason that's important
is because your fastq file is not in
that docker image
and the file that it writes it doesn't
write to the docker image
it writes to your local directory
so it's finished and it's just cleaning
up now
and we see that it took about 38 seconds
to run through
i think in this case there's about 400
reads and now what i'm going to show you
is in addition to the original file
which is the one that we
we used as inputs of the scrubber
there's a new file and that new file
has the same name as the input file with
the added extension clean
and if you look at the size of the files
you can clearly see that the original
file
is a bit bigger than the clean file
that's because
what scrubber has done is it's removed
just about 139
spots if i'm not mistaken and
what we can do
is look at some of those differences
and all i'm going to do is take this
spot
for this reed this reed was removed from
the original fastq file because it was
flagged
as human so let's take that
we paste it in this window
okay i think that's the right sequence
let me make sure
i missed some let me get the whole
sequence
i hate to miss a few bases
all right so
now i am going to actually go back
to my save
i'm going to view there it is
and we're just going to blast it
and so this is blasting a 194 base pair
read and we can see
without doubt that that reed was
correctly
flagged as human some really nice
identity there
so that's just an example of how we use
the scrubber
and this is of course just an example of
how good it really works i can tell you
that i had
randomly selected for this demo
two reads they were just the first two
runs just the two
first two runs i could find that had
sars2
and in both cases submitted from state
labs
the scrubber found very convincingly
uh human reads and removed them and
these were important reads to remove
because
in at least one case even i would have
had no
trouble probably finding a pii in it
so with that let me go back to the
presentation here
i will say in the presentation i have
screenshots of the demo i gave
so you can see the commands that i
executed and the example of the output
and now i'm going to hand it back to
chris who can kind of
wrap it up so go ahead chris
oh am i back on yes you are
right so um thanks can i hope that that
technical explanation was helpful for
a broad audience basically
we just want to point out that we have
built a fast
an extraordinarily efficient tool that
can be used
scalably on shared compute resources or
in the cloud
or anywhere you really want it
is extraordinarily specific for
identifying
identifying reads that are going to
definitely belong to a given species
we've also made sure to not exclude
reeds that should not be excluded
we're looking at you know essentially
microbiome samples viruses
or bacteria and so
our human scrubber database has
subtracted out
any k-mers that might be found in uh you
know
consistent with bacterial genomes or
viral genomes
so we're not going to remove things that
should not have been removed
but the statistical analysis
shows that it is extraordinarily
successful
at identifying any reed that might
actually be of human origin
particularly ones that would possibly
contain
uh identifiable snips or uh or
identifiable sequence
the method works it's successful you can
compare it
um yes if you if you use our tool
and scrub a re
a you know a given sra run and then say
oh i'm going to line this to human
you'll find that something's aligned
but if you decide to align it to mouse
those same reads would align basically
we're
we're um removing everything that could
be human
and we have not found any evidence that
we're missing something of significance
um nor if we had any complaints from
anyone who has used it
i encourage you all to check it out
we've got links
it's effective and it's fast and it
works
hi chris i'm just going to take that
and just say a few things quickly uh
first is
while i we do have the manuscript that
has been submitted for publication
and um i did submit it into
bio archive but it's still on the
screening process and
i haven't had my email on so i don't
know the status of either of those
i had that email off because i didn't
want to be disrupted when i gave the
talk so i apologize for that
the second thing i will i would like to
point out is i was terrible
i i totally disregarded the instruction
i was given and i ignored the chat
i'm happy to answer any questions at all
um some of them are very very good um
i don't know if you uh i'll i'll let
duncan decide how to do this i suppose i
don't know if you want me to look
through for the good ones duncan you
pick the good ones
uh i will also say anybody is welcome to
send emails or contact me by any means
i'm happy to talk about it uh
i think that's about it except probably
the most important slide
which is that one um
there are many more people than this who
have worked on the scrubber of course
the most important in some ways is the
last oleg shuitav who did a lot of the
great work
i want to thank everyone who helped me
in all my endeavors
writing the paper understanding the code
pursuing these wonderful
tools that we can share with our
colleagues so
i think with that i might hand it back
to someone else
i can lead off on questions and i it
looks like from the chat there's
actually quite a few
sure go ahead we can we can lead over
the anna's question which is a
question really how does something like
this handle things like endogenous
retroviruses
well it's an interesting question so the
first
point of view the first point to make is
in our normal
normal state tool as you saw how we make
a normal stat database
for normal stat analysis the way that
works is
perfect for such a complexity because a
human endogenous retrovirus
is going to a k-mer specific to that
retrovirus that matches something in the
virus kingdom is going to merge up the
tree and it's not going to stay with the
human diagnostic tools
now you can argue about whether that's
good or bad and reflecting the
complexities of biology but
if you know that that's what's happening
in analysis you can isolate that
uh sequence in in that manner now in the
human
scrubber database that oleg built
i actually believe there may be a few
more
of those retroviral potential retroviral
sequences
in the database but i when i say a few
more i mean one or two because remember
again
he purposely did this by subtracting all
bacteria
and virus anarchy bacteria from the
human
uh refseq k-mer database that he built
so those retrovirus sequences will be
gone
any other questions i'm trying to read
and type at the same time
needless to say i think you will have a
number of labs that will be eagerly
uh i know that this uh the tool has at
least been
alpha tested by a few labs i think
there's
going to be a lot of interest in both
running locally as well as uh but having
a better understanding of what's running
under the hood at sra
so um i'll just leave it open for
questions for one more
minute hey duncan this is lee
shirley i know you asked this in chat
but i thought it's worth pointing out um
just explicitly asking how do we get to
the singularity image
i'd love to try this out and then one
more follow-up question
to you guys is um can this be
generalized to things that are not
source code v2 because
i mean there's there's jeff definitely
some obvious
applications later on
yeah first of all let me let me
answer your second question first and
i'm always happy to talk to another cat
um heck yeah so
this is not in any way directed
at uh sars2 uh clinical samples
except to the degree that that's we hope
uh
a very actively being pursued by labs
everywhere that human scrubber database
is again aggressively removing human
uh potential human pii but it leaves
intact
any back any bacterial or viral
a clinical pathogen sequence read that
may exist so
it's not really specific to sars2
there is a specific tool based on stat
that's available but that's
for uh people who want to identify the
virus in the sample it's
it's in some sense the opposite um
and i've forgotten your first question
lee can you remind me
um just the um the actual applied like
how do we actually get the singularity
image and i'm saying singularity because
it's a lot easier on our shared
resources
yeah absolutely it's um
i i i think i can ask someone to add
this to the spheres chat
but this docker image right here
um is available publicly to
point at and it's in these slides i
assume the slides will be shared and
also we can
send that with the docker image
the docker command that i ran maybe even
with a little explanation
again that's in the slides but we'd be
happy to share it on the
on the spheres channel and i would love
people to hit this
simply because while i i think of this
really as a
beta version simply because i didn't
package a test with it and put it in a
really prominent
public location which would be docker
hub
it really is the same package and i'd
like people to use it
and if there's any problems find those
problems out now
but i anticipate moving this to a very
public location
and docker hub within a week
hey ken this is rodney just to kind of
pick up on a couple of things i've been
hearing the questions
uh first thing do we chris ken and
others do we agree that these fears
slack channel would be a good place to
communicate
with folks who want to uh test out
the scrubber and exchange information
there
one's on that one but yeah right so if
there's not
if people are not on that channel that
need to be on that channel let's surface
that immediately
and then maybe we can create a a little
discussion
tab there that we can have continue to
have this discussion i mean clearly
we're interested in getting as much
feedback as quickly as possible
i think it goes without saying that many
of you see that this is a very scalable
approach and as we talk about
very large numbers of submissions coming
into sra
we would like to have this approach sort
of being used and we would more
importantly we would like the
submitter community feeling comfortable
around this approach
so i mean however we can get there as
quickly as possible is really key to me
and then second thing i kind of want to
make a shameless plug here
obviously k-mer approaches can be used
for a variety of different things
they are effectively a sequence search
tool
in some ways you want the sequences to
be searched and then scrubbed
and then in other ways you want the
sequences to be searched against
a high background right so we've had
teens working
on using kmr approaches
since i believe february around sarco v2
uh you can imagine them being used for a
variety of specific applications
including the detection of very specific
alleles within read sets
um we're particularly interested in sort
of addressing concerns that might arise
in surveillance data that comes out of
sewage samples and other metagen of what
are the so-called metagenomic sets
and i say all this from my shameless
plug that
doe and nih have started
a sort of project together it's a
transagency
approach to solving sequence search
across the entire bolus of sra data
and one of the sort of sort of first
targets
will be sequence search that um is
capable of working against meta genomic
sets
so if there are folks here that are kind
of interested in that from a development
standpoint
i would love to hear from you this
project is in the very early stages i've
talked to some of you
a little bit about this in the past um
it's a go
and so we'd love to hear that kind of
commentary too
because i do think these k-mer
approaches can offer us some high
sensitivity
high precision methodologies
in terms of viral detection not just for
sores but for a variety of different
viruses
thank you very much all right thank you
all thank you ncbi i think uh again i
think there's going to be a lot of
interest in uh
taking this for a spin and i'm sure
there will be lots of uh
potential test pilots well great thank
you we look forward to you spinning it
around
yeah i am going to say it just started
as a um
a big dumb biologist idea and
it turns out it works really well um
surprisingly well
but i think you know anything that will
give labs confidence in
uh you know a what they're transmitting
to repositories would be
if they choose to have it done on the
sra side understanding what's happening
behind the curtain
yeah i think that's that's very helpful
when ken did one simple demo
but we've done the differential analysis
of full-on
genome alignment versus using using our
scrubber tool
and the differences come down to some
odd
just low complexity sequences basically
i mean nothing that you could blast
specifically to a human genome um
i understand any uh you know any
skepticism but i encourage you
to check it out and provide feedback
it's past it works thank you again